you created this new hula series and I
love this idea it's called there's
Johnny it's set in 1972 and I love the
conceit of this show of course the
greatest talk show of all time was
Johnny Carson show for 30 years that's
what I grew up watching but Johnny's the
guy that made me want to you know try to
do some some version of some weird
version of this and and you created a
show where it's about someone who works
yep yeah scenes and it's a kid and and
it's 72 which is when the Tonight Show
moved to LA so it really kind of took
off then and it's a cultural thing but
there's a kid who really lives on a farm
in Nebraska and just thinks that he has
a job so he finds his way to California
to find out he there's no job but he's
such a nice kid they kind of let him
stay like a puppy and he's just brought
into this world of sex drugs rock and
roll Hollywood 72 and here's my favorite
part of the show my favorite part of the
show is that you got permission from the
Carson estate to use actual footage of
the show so your act interacted yeah
it's in the show so well we could just
show a clip of it oh yeah yeah I think
we have at this show I have seen we
don't have a clip act it out you'll be
Johnny and all these Sammy Davis jr.
thank you you know what I've been
watching it and I said do we get a clip
and I don't think they gave us why all
that cost money and Hulu is very very
tight they they go by the way and a lot
of people said wait I don't have Huell
and here's what I say it doesn't it's it
does it drops that's the word the kids
use no it drops in November November 60s
but here's when I said get Hulu get like
the 30-day free trial don't spend the
money watch the show enjoy it tell a
friend and then get the hell out of it
yeah
they're gonna love they're gonna love it
you say don't send a clip next time you
know what I'm sayin all right
[Applause]
you